although there are people in the
Philippines they're called a bajao and
they have enlarged spleens and so
because they were seafaring people they
basically evolved to be able to hold
their breath for long periods of time
and then walk underwater and spear fish
so it's in maybe it's in my blood I
don't know that's incredible that's like
Sherpas yes they have like that
increased lung capacity because the
altitude's so high
[Laughter]
[Music]
those girls are absolute athletes yeah
they're totally yeah yeah it's very
tough that I can't I can't even imagine
like the the arm strength the back
strength the core strength core I could
climb it oh yeah I love climb a stripper
pole toucan I've never tried but I just
assume I can I'd love to see this how
are you with the President's Fitness
Challenge when you were a kid were you
able to climb the Rope up to the ceiling
yeah as a kid yeah yeah it took me three
days but I got there so then yeah you
probably thank you yeah yeah yeah it's
slippery though what what the poll is I
find the poll very slippery oh yeah yeah
it might be because it's metal usually
it's metal and then your body heat and
if you ever have any lotion or whatever
on well you've tried it I've tried I
used to go to uh stripper dancing
classes I I took twerking classes and
stripper dancing classes it's a very
challenging whoa twerking is really hard
I think is it the butt thing it's the
butt thing yeah yeah you got to work
I've never tried it I've seen you do it
Peter Kim well I did it yeah but it
wasn't good
I don't have the ass to do it I don't
have a Brazilian ass
can do it yeah I think it's a lot to do
with your ankles too yeah oh wow
your ankles yeah it's your ankles your
ankles yeah
you shatter your ankle
[__] hurt that hurts so bad
um see all that you can do now that you
quit you quit
chewing tobacco
it's a new Addiction yeah
um so you did twerking and what else
have you done uh uh I did
um stripper uh like no not yeah stripper
workout
um the burlesque workout I was belly
dancer for years all this Fitness stuff
um I did some Flamenco which is really
hard
it's so hard is there a lot of arm it's
everything it's so challenging it's like
the hardest dance I think that and tap
really hard it's like math what's the
other one the Irish the river
so hard seems hard it's very tough yeah
yeah and um so it's a lot of moving your
feet really fast yeah yeah again at all
I get a panic when I see river dancing
yeah yeah because I just go I I well I
maybe because I know I can't do it are
you good at high knees what's a high
knee like you know just are you able to
like jog with your like hineys in place
can you put your knees up to your chest
when you jog
that can you go past your ways like I
could do that oh okay yeah yeah let me
try
the presidential uh challenge right
fitness challenge
yeah
yeah yeah
so I can see I could do a lot of things
yeah and so when I see a pole I go I
think conquer it that makes sense you
know what I mean but I don't think that
I could I'll probably go up once if I
was a stripper slide down and now take a
break
yeah yeah I wouldn't get a lot of tips
they don't just climb though they uh
spin on it and they go upside down and
they do all sorts of things that you
know it's just pretty incredible yeah
I've been there so great I've seen it
very athletic yeah I've seen I've seen
such an art form
um Margaret
saying you were a dominatrix yes at one
point yes I'm not a good one though
because I am I'm so passive
do you mind if I choke you yeah I don't
really have an opinion about it and also
I don't find it sex